ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata come potete
vedere ci sono state delle piccolissime
modifiche abbiamo direttamente buttato
la cucina
lavoreremo con frutta e verdura cioè con
questa specie di ziggurat botanico al
solo scopo di creare del cibo che
accompagna il cibo e che quindi
rendendolo più bello automaticamente lo
renderà più buono visto che non siamo
capaci a fare le cose buone almeno
cerchiamo di fare le cose belle senso
quindi non cugini no tagli nessuno deve
rischiare a morte per avvelenamento
comunque facciamo subito vedere di che
cosa avremmo bisogno oggi un po romela
arancia susina banana proprio nell'inno
venete falli botanici presa una zucchina
e questo è un cetriolo e delle banane ma
vada posta mo caritas come si chiamano
pachino è una pera che esistono un sacco
di decorazioni che si possono mettere
nei piatti per farli sembrare più belli
con le varie verdure gli avvocato che ne
abbia deciso di non mettere perché basta
lavorato per questo video gianmarco ha
trovato delle diciamo possiamo definirle
composizioni da farmi provare io non so
cosa servirà tutta questa roba
dovrò semplicemente cercare di
replicarle la prima cosa devo fare cos'è
il fungo questa piena cacata gianni
mezzo al tuo paesaggio sarà bellezza
sarà bellissimo ho bisogno di una mela
ma scusa da mina come fai a tagliarla in
modo che sembri un fungo con la meglio
visto
cioè mai visionato anche tu lo schifo o
solo io ma tu questa né la ripresa
iniziamo a fare il corpo del fumo io
direi che la base la faccio
particolarmente capito in modo che possa
stare bene in piedi e non riguardano di
avere queste doti da spettatore infatti
non sembra quella che si fa ma che ora
ora la ri finirò è vero se non sono
bravo che hanno un problema ma scusa
perché ricordandosi certi la cava e che
sono stupido prendiamo questo punto la
mela fondamentale adesso il taglio più
grande mammamia guarda se deve fallire
alla singola così fra il coltellaccio
grosso tran tran
ecco lo ricaccia nei commenti qui sotto
bisogna mettere i voti da 1 a 5 questo
ma non per date però io posso di che mi
fa cagare gli darei 13 altre bisogna
scrivere fungo due punti poi dare minori
e tutto quanto a buy angolo rossi non le
farà qui devo trovare qualcosa che leggo
meno le parole
in congelatore però cominciamo ad alzare
l'asticella perché questo qui veramente
un sudore il delfino banana
voglio il delfino banana ma non è un
delfino questo una banana
per prima cosa devo tagliare la testa
incidere sotto e spellarli che non si
sia rotto perfetto cosa sono queste cose
le costole ragazzino ma fermi la testa
non andava tolta ho sbagliato
scusate rifaccio tagli diamo qui senza
arrivare alla fine si incide così fino a
giu infatti fatta a me sembra che questa
buccia sia più dura di quella che cosa
lui la sua proprio si piega
tranquillamente questa qui si spezzerà
in 200 mila parti e poi di rete non c'e
la pace tanto lo so qui gli si spezza
via in modo che vede la testa rimanga
attaccato una testa colposa tagliamole
costolina ora la coda bisogna fare
mostruoso ok
ecco che poi la buccia la bara neanche
una delle cose più tosti esistono al
mondo non c'entra niente perché è
importante che si è bello
questo verso delfino immagino scusate mi
sembra una creatura infernale questo
coso occhio che arriva la scuola ci sta
tu sei un calzino
forse un calzino questo qui ragazzi
accendiamo i chiodi di garofano non è
prendere entrato vennero del tanto non è
che la mangio la buccia e nero grosso
spesso esse è un'altra cosa
questo potrebbe essere divertente a fare
con i bambini posso dirlo la piazza
sopra sulla buccia il pilot di loro dal
filo con la scoliosi
ma sulla buccia
ecco qui il nostro delfino continua
tuttora a lungo tre al fungo e due al
delfino il premio simpatia perché sono
era uno è quel punto di me stiamo per
fare una rosa ragazze tagliamo la
zucchina un terzino prenderei un
prossimo volume turno non ha idea di
cosa il tema il peggio e sono distratto
senza un petalo dai cominciano
anche questo è fallito perché avevo
preso male le misure prima se avesse
avuto più tempo non stare con un petalo
in meno aspetta smetta e difficoltà
specie di ragione e manca il fungo
contato un colpo da d'un colpo
tu sei vedere nel deserto vede una nota
quindi vedere guarda che cosa sta
creando lui sta facendo una porcheria
sì ci sei bravo il demo gorgone il fatto
cioè colei che hai sbagliato tutto
ma nell'insieme e marco se tu serve una
cosa così a tavola tutti a testa bassa
la serbia le do due vogliamo fare vedere
dal pubblico da della rosa no no guarda
vista così qui c'è una scala allora
cetriolo dov'è il cetriolo
ok non lavato con la polvere la muffa
ora tagliamo così si taglia un
pezzettino che qui
e a questo punto questa è la parte più
difficile tutto ciò non è che sia di
generi queste cose per niente e falso
allarme e ancora io ho già perso la
milano dove sono potrebbe uscire da solo
importantissimo è un'altra grave di
tagliato il cetriolo inserite lo
stuzzicadenti qui in alto il bisogno di
far uscire
qui in alto e non ci credo non ci credo
rarissimo
[Applauso]
io ogni donna può 4b orino 5 c'è un
piccolo problema che non perché non sa i
piedi non 74 ci togliamo il pensiero una
canzone con stoppino quindi ho capito
come devo fare l'orsetto ragazze quello
che vi faccio vedere realmente cosa una
parte un po più larga un'altra pochino
più piccolina a questo punto come si
chiama l'orsetto a questo punto prendete
questa parte qui
incidete qua sopra
in questa zona dovremo infilare le
orecchie
1 prendiamo questa e tagliamo questo qui
è un'altra cosa carina fregano i bambini
e ragazze impazziscono gli adulti pure
ma fino al tipo di taglio taglio finché
non avrò vedete questo cash
tagliamo una v davanti un sorriso così
vado dritto per dritto e mi fermo un
pochino prima di metà sotto faccio la
stessa cosa e la ricongiunga a questo
punto lotta meraviglioso tratto pen
perché in realtà bisognava mettere i
chiodi di garofano ma non ce l'abbiamo
e a questo punto tagliamo le dobbiamo
fare una specie di dadolata di frutta
fondamentalmente accadesse fa una
spremuta nel frattempo prendi larini e
glieli metti tutti dentro
5 fatto la cacca dai questo è delizioso
cosa succede una modifica sarà in questo
modo la difficoltà
mettilo morera hai dato 3 al fungo ad
essere al momento della verità il
momento del cigno a b c d che pensa con
di tagliamo a metà lamela
ok abbiamo degli ospiti ma c'è marco ma
tu sei pazzo eh sì è troppo taglio
portando verso il giunta verso il ju e
taglio verso il ju taglio di lato un
taglio di lato hanno filato immoralmente
di fare questa cosa
12 sentiro pacilio vivo italia guarda
invece questa bellissima alla ad andare
dritta bilancio viaggio viaggio viaggio
coltello vediamo se ha fatto bene lo sto
capendo aver sbagliato a cagare in
obliquo dovrebbe essere uno due tre
ricapitolando tre volte e scendete giù e
vi fermate prima di arrivare al fine è 3
volte andate in dentro e vi fermate
prima di superare diciamo la metà a quel
punto avrete la possibilità di
sfogliarli proprio lui prende un'altra
meta di mela incido qui e scendo creo
questa cosa qui un anatroccolo un po
brutto era ma c'è un bel cigno qui
davanti a me
vedete non capisco come possa
appiccicarsi unico figlio
picchi nella polpa
parole forti enrico l'ultima cosa da
fare è proprio quella di aggiungerci la
coroncina
questo è il cigno perdonatevi meno
merito
ora di michele e mezzo il pungolo città
belle gestacci è stata dire
effettivamente ragazzi questo qui è il
risultato finale ho bisogno di chiederti
una cosa prima di chiederlo vi ricordo
di iscrivervi al canale attivare la capa
le notifiche mettermi un bel pollice su
per il se ti è piaciuto questo video e
soprattutto ricordarvi che giovedì
prossimo alle 14 esce un nuovo video
detto ciò fatemi una scala dal vostro
preferito al vostro sfavorito per favore
abbiamo il cigno il calzino il fungo la
scala la rosa e l'orsetto a voi la
scelta anche se secondo nei ragazzi di
cenere uno solo il fungo grazie mille
per averci seguito ciao
piazzando è bellissimo